okay good afternoon everyone I'm subra
Suresh president of the University every
time I come to the school of computer
science I always feel overdressed and
and and and one weekend I was here in a
t-shirt and I was overdressed so I just
I just wanted to mention that and I
think andrew is making me feel more and
more that way and IIT save all the time
about it welcome and you know it's a
this is the official kickoff of the 25th
anniversary of the official founding of
the school of computer science at
Carnegie Mellon University and in my
until I came here about 15 months ago I
had the pleasure of knowing about
Carnegie Mellon quite a bit from the
outside new many of its illustriousness
faculty who are also miss several of
whom were friends of mine when I was
outside Carnegie Bella and I hope they
are still my friends and one of the
things I knew about it was the impact
that this institution has had and this
school has had on a global scale and in
one of my previous jobs computer science
was a domain that reported to me in
another institution which which is a
competitor and one of the things I
realized since coming here is that this
school of computer science is even
richer even broader even deeper and even
stronger than I ever knew from the
outside so it's a it's a great pleasure
for me to be part of this this wonderful
school in my current role at Carnegie
Mellon University the founding of this
cool as you know very well started with
an unusual concept of bringing together
people from at that time for different
departments mathematics
electrical engineering psychology and
business and of course the pioneers who
created this flavor at that time
included people like herb Simon Allen
Noel and Alan Perlis and many others who
were here I was just looking at projects
itting over there and were played a
major role in influencing the direction
of the school there are many interesting
flavors of the school that we could talk
about one of the things that jumps to
mind is this was viewed by the people
who created this not only as an entity
or as in subpart of Carnegie Mellon
University or a school that focuses on
computer hardware software and all the
impact it can have but the unusual
perspective at that time to take was how
to combine the engineering and
technological aspects of computers
whether it's hardware software
applications coding etc or devices or
large computers at that time with the
human condition so it's how do humans
interact with computers not with respect
to just human machine interactions but
cognitive functions concept of learning
learning outcomes and that permeates not
just in computer science but through the
entire campus through this day and the
influence that this school has had
directly and indirectly in furthering in
pioneering and also in impacting that
perspective on a global scale is quite
profound the other point I would like to
make is the my own perspective not as a
computer scientist but as an engineer
and a scientist engineers and scientists
appreciate computer science but we live
in at a point in time if you are a human
being and a citizen of the world you
cannot avoid computing
it influences your life in every way
every day so how do you so that gives us
a unique perspective in shaping the
grand challenges of the 21st century in
ways in which we may not have thought of
you who are just thinking about super
computers or super computing or even
feels like computational biology etc how
do we alter the human condition through
computing and whether it's in health
care whether it's in communications
interactions networking among seven
billion people on the planet etc etc and
as a result I think that's that's one of
the most powerful things this being the
leading school of computer science with
its impact and we're going to see this
in this panel shortly we can dare to ask
some questions because of what I just
said about the 21st century so about it
almost a year ago when Eric Schmidt was
here last November for my inauguration
we were talking in the in the green room
just before the event and we just
started talking about just semi jokingly
beginning the conversation what would
the world of computing be like if CMU
had not created a School of Computer
Science 25 years ago then we stretch
that think a little bit what would our
day-to-day life today be like if CMU had
not created a school of computer science
and then we can stretch the topic
further which is the theme of the 25th
anniversary now that we have a school of
computer science which is so
distinguished what is the world going to
look like 25 years from now with all the
rich history that we have had and
extrapolating if you're a conservative
maybe you want to extrapolate linearly
at least linearly if you are somewhat
ambitious and optimistic like me I would
extrapolate it exponentially and and I
think
this is what makes it very exciting this
is what makes the school very exciting
and at this very exciting time I'm also
very pleased to have Andrew more as a
partner in this journey with me leading
the School of Computer Science and
Andrew for those who may not know I
think there are very few people here who
don't know Andrew as being a faculty
member at Carnegie Mellon University in
2006 he was attracted by Google to start
Google Pittsburgh which has now grown to
about 300 employees and it's in the
process of tripling its footprint in
bakery square and when Andrew and I
started to talk early this year it
became abundantly clear that only
Carnegie Mellon has the opportunity that
every university president would dream
of and that is to poach one of their
employees from an organization that has
more resources than God
and so when he and I met at our
residence for dinner to talk about this
we talked about why it was interesting
to him to even contemplate coming back
to Carnegie Mellon and he said exactly
what i said earlier and that is of all
the institutions he knows CMU has an
opportunity to shape the human condition
in the 21st century through computing
and computers morceau de day-to-day
lives not just computation day-to-day
lives more so than any other institution
so we are delighted to have Andrew join
us as that as the dqp and the panel will
dementia at least demonstrate in during
our year-long celebration of the 25th
anniversary and number of different
facets of school of computer science one
example of that that to begin with today
is our the conversation that Andrew will
have with serkan DNT know who is a
relatively recent graduate from 2004 in
computer science and he started in the
finance business very quickly moved to
Facebook in 2007 in California and then
since 2010 he's been heading up
Facebook's engineering efforts in New
York City and he has played a very
important role in the way in which
Facebook's many portfolios have evolved
on a global scale and watched the
transition in a very very fast and it's
it I had the pleasure of meeting him
last fall in New York City and it was a
great opportunity to welcome him back to
campus today so I very much look forward
to participating in the School of
Computer Science 25th anniversary
celebration during this year
and andrew has been pushing me to clear
my calendar as much as possible so that
during this year I can devote a lot of
time to the school of computer science
which it very richly deserves which I am
thrilled to accommodate to the fullest
extent that I can and and I want to hand
the microphone over to Andrew to kick
off the 25th anniversary events and also
I want to offer my congratulations and
thanks to the faculty staff and students
who played a major role in impacting
computer science around the globe
through this wonderful school I'm just
looking at an hal jordan who working
with the president of the university at
that time played a role in this and and
thank you angle and thank you for coming
today and i look forward to watching the
celebrations as they evolve during the
course of this year thank
thank you very much subra let me
introduce circum to you all this is the
guy we're going to learn more about him
as we're talking later maybe okay okay
that's right that's right but first we
have a little surprise a little surprise
for our esteemed president and one thing
about this particular room is it's a
place where if you look there are name
tags on the backs of plenty of seats of
be people will be supporters of the
dream of the School of Computer Science
over the years some of our the people
who built this the way it should be
including our fine previous collection
of Dean's whom two of them I see here
Raj and Jim right there so the names of
the people who have had this huge impact
on the school that we're all now members
of I hidden on the seats all around this
auditorium and now today there is a new
name which we have snuck in be 13 13 is
to celebrate the fact that in 2013 we
got an awesome new president and the B
we couldn't think of a good answer so
I'm just going to say so far appears to
be a bloody good president
thank you very much the way I know
Subaru you you're having to head on
because we are doing the alumina alumni
events immediately afterwards so super
is going to have to disappear now but
we're just wanted to thank you very much
your kind words and support thank you
all right before you can sit down
actually we're both sit down it's much
more relaxing to sit down I know about
you I feel a little awkward because I
haven't really done this kind of talk
show formats in academic place I just
wanted to mention one thing up super has
already introduced serkan and he's had
this amazing career amazing impact
here's an example of a phenomenon which
we cannot forget we've got to keep
remembering and communicating to
everyone we know the CMU school of
computer science undergraduate program
is incredibly successful the statistics
show just how many people want to become
a part of it and they also show and so I
could have seen this in facebook I've
seen it's in Google I have friends from
drop box from amazon from microsoft who
said the same thing the trajectory in
the career paths of the people coming
out of that program the SAS
undergraduate program are not just
similar they are strictly faster
superior to those from every other
school in the world there's no kind of
oh we're kind of doing number one with
other people and having good computer
science programs about this we are
absolutely ambiguously unambiguously
number one most recent report from our
Washington Post looking at this from
recruiters asking them the same question
Carnegie Mellon absolute number one the
folks coming out of our program and
later on as the months go by and I'm
continuing to do my dealings stuff here
we're going to explore this exactly why
and how this phenomena happens but it is
happening right now our people aren't
just high IQ they can get things done
they can work together and this has been
extremely good for Carnegie Mellon
having these successful people out there
in the world a fantastic example of this
is sucking himself I really admire
what's happened to your career so far
thank you so anyway first I wanted a
little round of applause for all of our
SCS undergraduates including circuit
have been so so so so setting up a
satellite office in New York doing a
really serious product and software
development isn't easy others other
skills that you think you learned or
tricks that you learnt while you're at
Carnegie Mellon that helped you to do
that yeah great question i'm sure you
have a perspective on this as well
having a groan and office here the one
thing i remember everybody's taken 251
great ideas i think there's a big piece
of the curriculum here that teaches you
to not just look at things and
understand the solutions to them but
understand how those solutions tie-in
sort of weird ways and manifest in
different in different places around
computer science and I think that sort
of boiling things down you know
sometimes it can be almost difficult
because it takes so much manipulation to
put new concepts into your brain once
you learned it to do that but even when
you start looking at human interactions
the way organizations are structured and
what makes people successful when you
start thinking about well what is
Facebook culture well you do the same
thing you say well I think it's these
core elements and those are the things
going to we're going to try to create in
New York and these are the things that
we think create those things and those
core elements do end up being the things
that work so there's there's a certain
fundamental nasai guess of the education
here that is really important in all
aspects of life I Greer that and I do
feel that sometimes setting up
successful organizations you are
actually having to do some of those
little block diagrams you might be doing
you in UML yeah for information system
it's very interesting what what do you
think as the years go by what do you see
curriculum of places like CMU how would
you like to see them develop yeah II
think should be changing as time goes by
well the first thing I want to call out
which is I think an integral part of how
Carnegie Mellon will
you to be the top CS program is
diversity in our field and I know that
seeing you has led the way I the stat as
I understand it is that forty percent of
the incoming class is female and there
are all types of other things yes that
dessert quite erotic loud you can't
spend a decade in our industry and not
notice that a lot of similar people I'll
put it that way and and with that that
says to me is that and you know when I
reflect on how I discovered computer
science it was pretty random and so so
much of the potential and so much of a
world in which people who understand
technology get more out of the world
than people who don't so much of that is
going to pass huge chunks of our
population by if we don't if we don't do
that so diversity is number one number
two I think people say this all the time
you know you in classes you get these
nice well-formed problems they're the
type of problems the way I like to put
it is they're the type of problems that
you need a big brain to solve right and
everybody here has big brain so it all
works out pretty well I think a lot of
the world and a lot of what we sort of
help people transition to when they join
facebook is a lot of the world is these
big hard problems that you need to chip
away at for a while you know a different
type of hard and and I think that that
can mean you know a lot of the
experiences you guys have like looking
at documentation trying to find a bug
you know working at things that take a
while but also having to go and track
down the person who wrote this code to
begin with or you know having to think
outside of the box or even having to
give a presentation god forbid you have
to open PowerPoint but sometimes
rallying other people to your cause is
necessary and I think those you know
it's hard to create those in a classroom
environment my idea was always we should
have the third thing that I'll say is
that you inherit a lot of code you know
a lot of times you didn't start with a
new file and in memory max you you
actually have to show up to some code
you don't understand read it make a
change and make it better and so I was
thought it'd be great if there was a
class where the code base stays from
year to year and just gets bigger and
each new class roadmaps
the next set of features and sort of
does what we do on a day-to-day basis
which is you know poke around in this
million line git repository that sounds
great I think there could be a cloth
segment on how to cuss the people who
came before ever effective use of get
land here totally agree okay that's very
good one thing that yep everything's
changing every year now and I think I
didn't invite you if you agree with this
but perhaps when we were younger it was
like every five years you saw the world
of technology feeling like it's changing
now it seems to every two years and the
advent of this mobile first world in
which I know about you but I think that
the the use of the browser and the model
of business is being based around the
browser is disappearing that's pretty
exciting but it also makes it very hard
especially for large successful
organizations already have a successful
business model to survive and
hypothetically I know people who've been
in large organizations which have had to
really think hard about how not to
become redundant in just two years mmm
how do you guys approach that and do you
do firstly i'm very interested in what
you think is going to happen next in the
world of mobile first absolutely yeah i
totally agree that you know while the
browser isn't going to literally die i
think it's going to be tougher and
tougher to get any mindshare in Silicon
Valley if or in you know in tech in
general if what you're doing is trying
to build websites that engage with
people websites already engaged with
people we've kind of covered that ground
we're now in this era where people have
devices in their pockets that are
ubiquitous they're getting powerful in
the way computers were a couple years
ago and we've just sort of scratched the
surface in how those things can
translate to being useful to people is I
think the big shift that we see is
websites which are kind of these static
screens that you use and you can
interact with and they serve lots of
different purposes but a lot of the way
you measure what a website is doing and
how useful how well it's doing it is how
much time people spend on it and how
many hits you get and how much time
people people are spending engaging with
your site whereas a phone if you have a
successful app you can buzz it at any
time it has all types of context and it
can be this sort of more
ensive useful thing for for you in all
types of different ways so I see a lot
of the conversation shifting from
engagement which is kind of the web way
things worked into utility which is
which which is a very different mindset
and I think unlocks a whole series of
problems that are going to get
increasingly increasingly difficult one
of the things we work on in New York is
is artificial intelligence and you know
it's not hard to imagine i'm sure
science fiction did this long before we
started working on it that you can talk
to your phone and not just ask it you
know to transcribe some text but also
ask a contextual rich questions about
the world around you and about you as a
person and all of these are things that
speak very directly to the experience of
having a mobile device and they're much
more difficult than building a website
and so I think we're about to see we're
already seeing an explosion in the
demand for specialized difficult tough
computer science problems as you know we
bridge this next gap where technology
meets people where they are instead of
where technology is now a lot of stuff
in there well I decide I know I really
like that answer and i think it is
actually really important to see that
the world really is changing and the
things that we as academics or folks are
doing startups all the folks are going
to go into companies see the goalposts
to change and we now really are into
this new world for me one of the biggest
changes I've seen related to what you're
describing is a few years ago the
cognitive boost that intelligent
machines gave you to help you find the
right documents the right documents
containing the right piece of
information now it's the right entities
and they're being able to actually
answer questions about these entities
and I just want to casually mention I
heard that there was some University
which gave the question answering power
that made the Watson system of IBM so
successful just remember which one that
was I think it was CMU yes yeah yeah
that's right and we have lots of people
who love doing that and I think people
here will be really excited to hear that
the New York Facebook office is working
this area because it's something we care
about so much absolutely all right I
know ask you another question this one's
very interesting because i was in sort
of in your position representing a
corporation and i love this question but
it's a very nuanced question you can
probably guess already what my question
is so dealing with baking things really
really good and powerful for the users
based on exploiting and causing good
things to happen based on their data is
really exciting and there's so many
times when you can brainstorm amazingly
powerful things that you could do for
the users based on the thing that we're
all experts at which is processing data
and coming up with good decisions so the
same time there's all kinds of
terrifying dystopian futures in which
data is abused in various ways you guys
must have to worry about all this little
time what can you say about your your
thoughts on yeah absolutely i think this
is this is some this is this is what our
generation is going to have to do we
have to have a conversation i think is
the answer so much technology has
technology has created the potential for
so much you know people spin off so much
more data that can be captured and will
be captured in Denver tantly if you're
not careful these days than they used to
and there's so much potential for that
data and of course there's so much that
we want to protect about that data and
privacy is something that's important to
people and I think what that means is
somebody and it can be legislators it
can be you know government it can be
private companies like Facebook and I
think this is something we're doing
needs to sit down and say well what if
the rules work this way what if the
things that are you know what if for
instance this is something that we
talked about the things that are on your
profile that's your space and so you
control them you can delete all those
things and you can do all these things
but the things that are on other
people's profiles are their space
there's a very simple organizing
principle for data and and it's just you
know the scratch on the surface of what
needs to be but I think we are going to
chip away at figuring out what these
rules look like and eventually they'll
be as intuitive to us as you know
downloading music in paying 99 cents a
song or any of these sort of like new
areas that technology is enabled but
right now we haven't had that
conversation and so it's very hard for
people to understand what's happening
with their data what that even means and
the I hope that we can have a
sophisticated dialogue about this and
that one of the things that we
contribute to the world is a good
nuanced intuitive ethical understanding
of what it means to have privacy and
also utility from the data that I create
and i own and I contribute to the cloud
or however you want to put it so I
always said there's no satisfying answer
this question very dad says I really is
racer but but I mean we just we just
don't know you know I talked to a
copyright lawyer I remember this
conversation and I pointed to all this
things that I thought were silly about
people creating mashups with songs on
how that was illegal and you know you
can listen to the first 30 seconds of a
song and then it's free and then after
that you have to pay some amount of
money and they're just all these weird
pieces of copyright law and you said to
me no formulation of these rules is
going to match your intuition because we
don't really have an intuitive sense of
how copyrights work like this is just
not a thing that you know basic ideas
about property ownership or whatever you
know speak to and I think the same is
true about our data we will find if we
do sit down as and have this
conversation will find that you know
they're there are things that we don't
totally understand about how we want our
data to be sword and represented in who
we want to have access to to it but
hopefully we can make those those rules
clear and people will understand what a
cookie is and have some have some peace
of mind knowing what's what's happening
with that I think that makes sense but I
want to push your one thing that you
said we sit down we figure out yeah you
think that we is is it people like
in this room and universities is the
folks in the corporate offices is the
engineers working for the oak corporate
called corporations should it be people
in Washington have who do you think the
we is to do this yeah I think well you
this this is kind of a fundamental right
i think that like privacy is kind of a
fundamental right and we should all we
should be building laws that match
everybody's sort of sense of ethics but
right now i think it's the engineers i
think you know nobody nobody really
knows it at the the level of depth and
it evolved so quickly that really only
somebody with a you know at least a
bachelor's in CS can tell you what's
happening behind the scenes so i guess
yes to your question but uh you know the
conversation really needs to start I
guess among us like the sort of the
people who know what what bites are and
are actually putting data into to use I
totally agree i really like the way you
said it i think it is it is actually
when when you're learning software
engineering or other aspects of computer
science these days you have to be
learning something or thinking about the
policy implications and the broader
implications and says such thing is a
pure technology technologist divorced
from the rest of this i totally agree
yeah so there's a whole bunch of other
folks i know we're going to want to ask
you questions and we did promise that
we're going to open this up to questions
so i'm going to hand over to the
audience now so let's give everyone else
a chance but thank you very much your
comments yeah now what I'd like guys if
folks just want to come down to the
microphones ask interesting insightful
questions feel free to ask questions
which makes irken squirm yeah make it
laughs this is a really good opportunity
for us to fabulous please introduce
yourselves let us know sort of the you
are what organization you're with be a
part of CMU or for your friend from
outside and you know that if you don't
do that and I'm going to keep asking
questions and questions we kind of
I actually have several but only 2 i'm
phil mason i was here from very long
time ago Mary I knew Mary before she
finished her degree so because then go
back that long um since one of the
things I don't know how the education is
done here anymore there is this the
sovereign genere institute was on how
you do better software engineering I
live in the Boston area and involve her
last several years and something called
a job which of course people know I
don't know where that is with regard to
the education environment how do you
teach the students not to compete
there's not somebody telling them what
to do they have the responsibility
themselves to self-organize how do you
how is that being done within
universities or in I don't know what
Facebook does so with regard to agile I
understand I mean the company I have the
most curiosity is Apple and nobody ever
it says how they do things i think the
facebooks a lot more open than that so
that's the first question great yeah I I
can't tackle the University side of this
but you can guess if you like I guess
yeah why I think you know we've been I
will say that you know one of the
reasons that Carnegie Mellon students
tend to be the best and this is an
empirical fact not a biased observation
from an alum but empirical fact we see
when they when they tend to join
facebook is they work hard they
understand that building things is
difficult and they're ready to put that
time in because they've you know gone
through the process here over and over
of working hard and reaping the rewards
and really the other world works at
Facebook famous thing you know the
poster that you see when you walk around
the officer says move fast and break
things and I think it's just things that
are excellent when you see something
that really is outstanding and when you
see a place that motivates people and
people feel like it they come to because
it's more
job they tend to be fast they tend to
have you know Thomas Keller has in all
of his restaurants this thing that says
sense of urgency I mean it really does
take that you have to want you know
viscerally you have to be you know
walking a little bit faster to your next
meeting you have to like really care to
the point where you're on the edge of
your seat that to do things and and so
the way we do that mechanically is we
make sure that people are motivated not
by promotion or whatever but by the joy
of seeing the things that they've built
being used by many many people and the
the reason that we tell them to come
work at Facebook is not that will pay
you this amount of money or or that you
can you know attain this title or
because the food is good even though the
food is very good but it's because you
will write something and you'll work
with other people that are brilliant and
then soon very soon millions and
billions of people will use it and that
is joyful so we tried it at every point
in our growth we try to get out of the
way of that that means that if somebody
complains that there are too many
meetings we take that seriously we're
very careful about the process you know
great examples it we always had a site
that we would when it was mostly a
website now there's mobile apps and
everything that we would push all of the
code that was in our repository to every
one of our you know X where X has a lot
of zeros after its servers every Tuesday
and that got more and more difficult we
have gigabytes of code and that code has
to be now compiled and run in a virtual
machine and there are compiler gifts
that have to go and thousands of
engineers have contributed to that code
and they're all these graphs what we
still do it in fact now we do it twice a
day one of those from New York because
of time zones and we have to use all
types of things like BitTorrent to get
the binaries out to the right place but
we decided to do that we decided we were
not going to slow down so I think we
just care a lot about velocity and I
think that is a tremendous competitive
advantage
something that I think everyone now
should see the power of and do a quick
follow-up question do it within Facebook
software engineering teams some teams
all teams on none of the teams sort of
used basically an agile one of the agile
methodologies some teams I think is the
answer you have like different flavors
you have teams that are working on you
know projects that are ambitious and you
know they're kind of things that we
think will have this effect but we're
not sure and we're playing in a product
space those are the products get naked
built and rebuilt seven times and before
they actually ship you have teams that
are really pretty like focused on one
metric that they they think is important
like the coverage of all the places in
the world where the owner of the place
actually owns the facebook page and
these these are you know more tactical
teams and moving more quickly more
likely to have projects on a whiteboard
that they check off every week and stand
up to every 15 minutes there's no
there's no set procedure for how to do
these things it's more just do them well
and move as fast as the people around
you are removing thank you hi my name is
Steve saporta I'm the parent of the
Carnegie Mellon suit and I'm a software
engineer in New York and I was wondering
what you see in terms of the computer
science and engineering students who
come to you sort of fresh out of school
the ones I've seen are all great
programmers but what do you see in terms
of their knowledge of source control of
design of issue tracking systems of
DevOps all the things that you have to
do in addition to writing code to be
successful what are you seeing and what
can the schools do to make people even
better at that yeah so I'm tempted to
say they don't know anything about any
of those things which is generally which
is sort of the short answer I think it's
actually getting better i think the
percentage of students that have like a
project on github by the time they show
up at facebook is going up which is nice
to see and I think you know we've had
these conversations with people and in
our schools for a while and given this
feedback so i think it's getting better
but you know to turn this into kind of a
positive thing that's my advice to
everybody here who's in an undergraduate
program build something yeah i would i
would say do two things sorry three
things providing i live in oakland board
a 5 11 things 11 things will go through
them in order three things i'm going to
live in myself to 31 is just build
something go to you don't have to you
can go to a hackathon and do it
overnight and that's awesome but you
know just build something and then put
it on on github and just going to go
through those motions so you don't you
know have any hesitation you know what
button to click and it's just like to is
just start a company and print business
cards and even if somebody is like oh
cool what is your company doing you like
we don't do anything we just decided to
print business cards that's fine that's
fine it you know again just go through
those motions get used to saying you
know i work at a company with these
people and we started it this is what
we're trying to do that's nine you know
ninety percent but that's a big big
chunk of what you can do and then the
third thing would be to tell tell these
guys what you like about your experience
here and like help them figure out how
to make you guys you know i use this
phrase before but feel like this is more
than just an undergraduate degree you're
here for this is like a piece of your
future and a place you'll always kind of
cherish let us let them know how to do
that very good ounces especially numbers
one and three number two I think you're
a nut case yeah I say that with great
respect yeah
is the first birth okay I have to have
another one by the way I just got an
email last week from LinkedIn that did
list Craig email and computer science as
the best place for think they said
programmers don't think they said
software developers I don't know if
anybody else here got that that email so
that's that was pretty interesting now
the question is complete different the
other one wearables where wearables in
the future yeah Wow um all over us I
don't know that much about this space i
have actually another carnegie mellon
alum my friend Christina just started a
company making a ring that you know
helps you know what's going on with your
phone without you having to take it out
of your pocket which is great I think
there's this sort of emerging place for
technology that isn't just something you
have to pull out and sort of look at
like I think they're all types of
different interactions or different ways
you may want to be notified about
different things and of course there's
you know this Apple watch I think a lot
of our industry is now kind of in pause
mode waiting to see what happens with
you know is Apple creating a segment are
they inventing 50 new idioms that we
know I have to to copy and market in our
own software but I think the one thing
that I'm seeing is that hardware is
really compelling I get asked about
thirty percent of the time whereas it
used to be zero percent of the time hey
do you know an electrical engineer
whereas it used to be one hundred
percent of the times you know a software
engineer and now you know when people
ask me for a software engineer more than
fifty percent of the time they mean in
iOS or Android developer so those trends
are those trends are pretty clear and I
think we're about to see another one of
those big shifts and hardware and
variables yeah that makes sense hi my
name is Ben Lichtman I'm a sophomore in
computer science here so you started to
address my point but I would sort of
want to focus on it I'm sort of going
through my first internships and what
I'm seeing is a lot of the course work I
do here is very theory oriented maybe
there's programming involved but it's
concepts its ideas and you mentioned 251
very idea based then I get to my
internship and as others have mentioned
you know they say do you know get you
know agile do you know these things um
but more than that do you have a a
working knowledge of software
engineering and so do you have
recommendations on how to go through
that growth process of equating both the
theoretical aspects of computer science
and the real applicable practical
aspects yeah i mean this is this is you
know we joke about like having having
people fiddle with with github and
things and I think there's it really
belies this point about building
software in groups it's very hard to run
a class where you build software in
groups but that's really all that
happens outside of school I think like
this is a really difficult one this is
also like you know we we have these
interviews where we get at how somebody
understands how processes will scale to
millions or billions of things another
thing that you really really can't give
people great experience with here
without you know millions of people
hammering your website every minute
that's not an experience that you get at
Carnegie Mellon internships are awesome
you're in your sophomore year you you
get to do three of these you get to
sample different companies you'll
probably work in different code bases
you'll kind of see how this works I
would love for more group based
collaborative projects that kind of get
you into this the one piece of advice I
would say besides like yeah this is the
thing you're going to learn in industry
is dig up some of your old code go try
to read it you know be sort of that
meticulous person about some things like
naming your variables or just you know
think of your code as something that
you're like printing out and then
mailing to somebody else and they have
to pick up and read because the
empirical truth that we see is that
you'll spend three times as much time
reading somebody else's code as you will
writing your own code and you just have
to get into the habit of that and it
will say in a place like Facebook people
are very concerned the thing that
motivates people day after day is
getting up and pressing their peers
that's true here in this problem
true anywhere you go where people are
really great and one way you do that is
you write some code that somebody's just
like that was a pleasure to work in I
know exactly how that works I want to
take that that design pattern and use it
over here why don't we generalize this
so now it's a platform if you're the guy
that wrote the abstraction that
everybody uses that's much better than
being you know the the vp of XYZ so just
get in that habit of doing it thank you
very much yeah I can I just do a quick
follow-up question for you so you also
have the experience of going through the
undergraduate here programming do you
remember that being a time when you were
cursing saying I wish I have been taught
these skills at CMU or do you think of
their things which someone is being
through see me you can pick up pretty
happily in their first few weeks or
months yeah so I did this like
intermediate thing where I went into
finance and that I think a lot of people
have the same experience that felt like
a step back like that quality that the
technology was there to service some
business need it consequently it wasn't
designed to be very reusable so when i
first joined facebook it was tough
because everybody was very good and I
was used to writing visual basic i think
is basically the right yeah the right
way to to put it but yeah the first time
you the first time says somebody says
send me a diff and you don't know what
they're talking about that is a bit of a
panic moment but luckily our tools are
pretty good I think I picked it up
pretty fast and it's just it's it's a
rite of passage we now boot camps so you
actually go through two weeks of just
like here's what this means here's how
to use this here's how to use this do it
once literally check in some code in
your first week here so that we know you
know how to do that and then go off and
join the team and I think that's really
helpful and hopefully other companies do
that so you don't everybody doesn't have
to start from scratching
be afraid great um no I'm Bob Murphy at
Marblehead for comp I oh here and I had
a question that was stimulated both by
the point about privacy and the point
about AI right now the primary mode of
the interaction between a machine
intelligence system and a user is a sort
of a request would you like to be
friended with this person right do you
see that mode disappearing do you see a
mode where an agent makes that decision
for you and says yes you yeah I want to
be you know I want to make that contact
I want to do this I'm willing to accept
that appointment I'm willing to you know
where it's not where everything isn't
being presented to you for making a
choice but somebody's some app is making
that choice for you do you see that
absolutely and I don't even think it's I
don't even think it's related to I don't
even think it's just intelligent agents
right now I think you look at our for
instance we have a big product where
people check into places and sometimes
they don't see because their GPS
coordinates are not that accurate they
don't see the place they want to check
into and so they go and create it and so
we have this constant problem of
duplicate places we have all types of
product reasons but we also discover
things over time we discover well okay
not you but a third person checked in
here and we're constantly having to
build these infrastructures that don't
wait for a request process some data and
serve it back but actually look at all
of the stream of information and at some
random point you know make some sort of
inference for instance you can imagine
i've wanted to build this product for a
while but we start to see photos come in
we start to see people checking in and
instead of putting these in people's
streams and treating them as one thing
we discover hey there was a wedding this
weekend and these two people got married
and and now we know that these are these
are the architectures of the future
where there's just streams coming in and
all these avenues with which you can
wake up somebody's phone or you can
commit something to a database so you
can send somebody an email and you know
of course there will always be queries
but there will also there's also just
more contextual streams of life
I guess that that need to be process and
it's a surprisingly deep systems
question because the the sort of query
mentalities so deeply baked in how we do
things now and the architecture of the
internet that things left to change very
good answer Jim hi I'm Jim Morris
something serkan said a few minutes ago
tell me thinking about the problem i
have this week i'm teaching a class
where I want the students to do a/b
testing and put it simply I don't have a
data stream or I don't have a website
that they can do a/b testing on every
website at Carnegie Mellon that I might
be able to give them access to if I do
the calculation of how many hours it
will take before I have significance for
my a/b test is I'll have to run that
website I have to do this test for about
two years it was case the websites
already changed so it's irrelevant so
you too may be anybody in the room but
you too especially from companies that
have these big data streams can tell me
what how can we arrange to give our
students access to this these torrents
of data Oh unfortunately this is really
hard because especially a company like
Facebook we move very fast and we grow
very fast and so the trust that we put
in individual engineers we put in them
it's a it's a lot of trust and it comes
with a lot of training and we're able to
put in them you know literally legally
because their employees and they've
there you know there's a lot of trust
that comes with that bit that we flip
that says you are a full-time facebook
employee and there's even more trust
when it comes to controlling users
experience and and running a/b tests and
I struggled to think of a way that we
could open that up to people that aren't
Facebook employees what I would love to
do is share maybe there's some way we
can generate synthetic data or something
that can give this experience but this
is one of the you know I talked about
the joy of putting things
in front of people eventually you you
know some you gather that joy because
you see people using them in your daily
life that's a small set of people
sometimes you over here people talking
about things or you see things in the
news but most of the way you experience
this joy is through looking at charts
and seeing all these things and you know
I don't know of a great way to like
transfer that outside of the walls in
facebook again very unsatisfactory
answer no it's it's really tough i just
want to do add one thing one of the
killers with the a/b tests is that you
can do a possession-based a/b test where
you go into a or b according to your
particular session may be based on the
single cookie of the single event ID
associated with that session but relay
be testing you often need to actually be
looking at similar users on similar
browsers or the same user in the same
browser of a multiple-time at that point
you're already in massively complicated
privacy-preserving systems and so aside
from the data volume the hassle a
difficulty of setting up a useful a/b
test is really tough as a maybe test
which was just based on individual
clicks or even short session events
usually doesn't answer the question
you're really interested in can I had
one thing that's just funny sometimes we
do a/b tests are nice you can just hash
a user ID and get nice random sample of
users but sometimes you test things that
have network effects like if it's a
message feature and can't just test that
on random users because they have nobody
sent messages to so we have to find
these small communities of people where
it's a small sample of all of our users
but people are very well connected and
that almost always means new zealand new
zealand is this like amazing right
network test bed because it's you know
relatively small but anyway so sorry new
zealand you see a lot of broken facebook
comments i don't have another company
which has another country which it does
that to ya say what the quran is
everybody's got their favorite country
that's hilarious all right i think up we
need to wrap up at this point i want to
make a couple of other just logistical
things lab firstly i see this printed
here i meant to say thanks for all the
great questions now that presupposes
these work great questions but i think
they work you can have a great
yeah I think they were great questions
okay very good the alumni awards are
coming up next they're in the kreski
theater in the College of Fine Arts
which is in that direction I want to
make a very important plug that the
computer science building and the
College of Finance are linked together
by a very important symbolic bridge
which happens to be also an extremely
literal bridge the Randy Pausch Memorial
Bridge which has wonderfully been
decorated for this SES and kaylee events
and you see you should definitely check
out the randy pausch bridge to see the
extremely nerdy and extremely a
meaningful decorations on that so it's a
look I'll get Taylor's it's
illuminations involving binary code I
haven't seen any equities not dark but
I'm looking forward to that that's going
to be great what do actually that's
everything one thing I finally have to
do is really thanks so could we hear
really appreciate the chance to see
what's going in the heads of folks from
companies like Facebook and to see
what's going on we're also really proud
and respectful of your personal success
in the success of the Facebook New York
office so thank you so much for coming